it's been put about this summer that
Hillsdale College is a political
conspiracy to support Donald Trump and I
will tell you that it isn't and the
reason is it wouldn't be any good at
that because when I got to know all
these kids that I called out how many
how many are here who graduated since
2000 would you stand up
[Applause]
[Music]
and I know every one of them and I met
them when they were 18 and we didn't
talk about the politics of the day we
talked about the meanings of things this
is a story I like to tell unruly and
useless Michael Lucchese is here tonight
and I had cause to tell it to him last
spring because I've kept there's a
wonderful book by Richard James Mellon
the face of Lincoln you should find it
in the used bookstore it's huge and it's
got these beautiful pictures of Lincoln
and on the other side of each picture is
something Lincoln said or wrote at the
time the picture was taken and I've kept
that on my desk for 40 years now
Claremont and now here and it's always
open to the same page and what's on the
other page is the strongest force on
earth and he describes it in an
interview with the journalist on the
night before he gave a speech in
Hartford Connecticut two days after the
Cooper Union address Lincoln was trying
to explain why it was right to condemn
slavery but not restrain it except where
the Constitution permits which means you
can't touch it in the states where it
exists already only in the territories
which by a happy accident that changed
history most of the land of the United
States was not yet States and Lincoln
gave this example he said if I see a
rattlesnake what I do about it depends
on where it is if it's in the yard I'll
get a stick and kill it but if it's in
bed with my children I might just leave
it lie because it might bite them if I
stir it up and this fella
the next day Lincoln's getting on a
train and he's very recognizable man and
this journalist said you got a ride on
this train and he said yeah and he said
I want to talk to you and like it said
fine and the man said Lincoln how did
you think of that and Lincoln gave this
answer he said when I was young and
studying law
said I would run across the word
demonstrate in the newspaper article
reprinted from The Hartford Courant
which has published till today the word
demonstrate is italicized I saw the word
demonstrate and I thought that must be
some higher kind of proof
have you read Lincoln it'll make you cry
it's so firm and true and good and
decisive see it's like reading Churchill
it's the same thing he said I ran across
this word and I thought I need to learn
to demonstrate and so I read and I
looked and I thought and I said to her I
read Blackstone and he said and I said
you know Lincoln you'll never make a
lawyer if you don't learn to demonstrate
a thing learn what that word means see
that's what college is by the way he's
learning what words mean that's why it's
hard that's why it's joyous so he said I
left my position in Springfield and I
went home to my father's house and I did
not come back to work until I could
repeat all of the proofs in the two
books of Euclid from memory do you see
the commitment it's it says it's as firm
and resolute and determined as being
willing to sacrifice your life to
sacrifice your focus and your
concentration to learn so it turns out
Hillsdale College is not a conspiracy to
support Donald Trump is to recover the
meanings of the terms that gave rise to
our nation so that we can explain them
and love them and fight for them and if
need be die for them
[Applause]
[Music]
our bond hello kids
our bond is that it's like if you play
poker a lot but somebody or you work a
lot with somebody or best of all if you
fight in a war with somebody and you
love them and you share something then
because of that right the purpose of a
college is to produce and share that
specific phenomenon and there is no
other and you know there's nobody I mean
almost nobody who works within five
miles of this space where we are right
now who could give an accurate
definition of that and yet they regulate
the living daylights out of it and that
brings us to the constitutional crisis
that faces the American people and I
won't explain that to you because
there's somebody here again our speaker
tonight is an important man
we the college decided that five or six
years ago how long ago was it he came to
the campus with his triplets and they
didn't enroll in our campus which is you
know what's wrong with that guy
it's always the parents fault but I'd
been hearing about him and studying him
up and I just saw him I didn't know he
was coming and I saw him on the campus
one day so here's what he is he's an
excellent golfer he's the father of
these triplets he's a graduate of
Georgetown and UNC School of Law which
means it's a miracle he has any good
opinions of any kind he's a former
member of the South Carolina House then
the South Carolina Senate and the US
House of Representatives
he's a controversial because he's
careful with people's money he's on in
others and he's controversial because
he's a stickler for the law I'm one of
his employees little Paul over there
do you see what a powerful man I am
I have the ability to break the career
of the very talented young Paul Ray and
I want you all to know that I'm not
afraid to do it
he sent me something today yesterday I
think I can't remember it was the
release from the White House about
Constitution Day and I'm gonna read you
a passage from it now I told you that
Paul works for this man and I haven't
said what this man does and I'm not
going to say because he's here in his
private capacity and we want you to know
what kind of man he is because whatever
service he's doing right now that's just
the beginning this comes from the White
House but it was sent to me by one of
his employees it says we are a nation of
laws and laws must be enacted by the
people's elective representatives the
Constitution ensures that the government
acts only with the consent of the
governed I know a senior person in the
FBI and I said to him not long ago I
hope you're not messed up in that and he
said I'm trying to keep the FBI
independent and I said independent of
what are you armed who gave you the
authority to be well he said never had
that question asked I said I think that
ought to come up more on the top floor
of the FBI
only with the consent of the governed
that's what guarantees that you can't be
governed the way a horse is governed
that vital safeguard consider the
government as expressed by the
representatives responsible to them I
could be reading from the Federalist
Papers here but I'm reading from a
document produced two days ago in this
city of all things that vital safeguard
is lost when obscure and unaccountable
regulators impose unforeseen mandates on
the American people or twist the plain
meaning of statutes to regulate without
authority from the Constitution our
Constitution will be of little avail to
the people Madison said when the law is
little known and less fixed that is
actually the point of the sphere that
will rescue our freedom and it comes
from that man Mick Mulvaney
[Applause]
[Music]
it's always fun to try and follow Larry
in a speech and I thank you very much
for that introduction thank you for
pointing out as I will here very briefly
to take care of this legality that I am
here tonight in my personal capacity and
not in anything that I do for living
from 9:00 to 5:00 or whatever hours
those might be I cannot tell you how
excited I am to be here tonight I do
this for a living pretty much I talk to
groups and I have talked to just about
every single one of the organizations
that I really admire I have talked to
the club for growth I have talked to
heritage I have talked to Hoover
Institute I've talked to a I had a
wonderful time with the folks at the
Competitive Enterprise Institute but
this this is the big one to speak to
this organization on Constitution Day is
is quite a pleasure thank you I
I think so highly of Hillsdale College
that it's actually one of the few
schools that I agreed to take my
children to go see they can go to school
for free in South Carolina said look if
I'm gonna pay for you to go to school
someplace else it better be a really
really good school and we went to go
visit Hillsdale and my children then 16
had the unusual opportunity to meet dr.
Arnn which when you're 16 can probably
be a little bit of a challenge he walked
in sat down looked at my Joe and said hi
I'm dr. Arne what's the most important
thing to know in life and my wife just
looked at me and I sit back and said
don't let him go I have no idea what the
what the two boys said but my daughter
who I love and is my favorite child and
she will tell you that said looked at
him and said I know know that she said
where is my towel okay now a lot of the
younger people in the room if you're
under the age of 50 got that Larry is
not under the age of 50 and had no idea
what that meant and looked at me like I
was from another planet and very clearly
decided my daughter could not go to
school there and we walked out the door
and my daughter says well I can't go to
school here and I said why cause he
doesn't get it for those of you who have
not read some of the more I guess you
folks in this room probably don't spend
much time reading douglas adams as
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy but in
that particular book I know where my
towel is or you know where your towel is
is code for a well-ordered life someone
who knows what's right and what's wrong
and how things are supposed to be in the
world and my daughter was really kind of
I thought it was a great answer because
I had read the book Larry had not my
daughter was really disappointed she
felt like she embarrassed herself and I
and Larry doesn't know this we left the
office and finished the tour the
University if you could bring up the
slide that would be great I saw this
okay this is on your campus right there
is a place where you evidently raised a
bunch of money and
or donors could put things on the brick
in the walkway so 10 minutes after my
daughter says that to dr. Arnn this is
what I found on the Hillsdale College
campus and that's what my daughter said
I'm really not going here at all so
[Applause]
that's right she made the mistake of
following her dad to his alma mater as I
sent here to try and figure out how to
do this and what to say to this group on
this particular day I realized I was
going to fail miserably and by the way
I'm scared to death because ordinarily
when I give speeches there's zero chance
that my parents will find out about it
since they both read your newsletter my
guess is they're going to hear about
this today which is why I'm wearing the
tie that my mom gave me and I can't do
what Larry can do and I can't stand up
here and give you speeches that that
quote Jefferson and and Churchill and
Reagan and Lincoln and Plato and
Aristotle I can't do it I tried before
and I failed miserably at those types of
speeches but as Larry was up here
telling the story about Lincoln it
occurred to me that I might be able to
do something else worthwhile and
interesting to you which is I might be
able to demonstrate something and that's
we're going to talk about today I'm
going to demonstrate something about the
government and something about the
constitutional crisis that we face in
the government now when I say the
government I want to be very clear who
I'm talking about because there's two
real groups of people in the government
the elected and the unelected the folks
that you elect about five hundred and
thirty-odd of those by the way in fact
the ones that you actually elect on an
individual basis are probably closer to
four or five president vice-president
your two senators and your member of
Congress and that's about it but all in
all there's just over 500 of those it's
just over two million unelected
non-military government workers in this
country and that's what I want to talk
about tonight that the bureaucracy but I
also want to start by making it clear
that I'm not talking about all of them
there are really really good government
workers there are really really good
bureaucrats many of them are in this
room Paul is a great bureaucrat
he just is I happen to think I'm getting
pretty good at it it hurts me to say
that after having been a elected right
wing Republican nutjob but I think I'm a
good bureaucrat why what what makes a
good bureaucrat what why is Paul good at
it because I think we do what we were
told to do under the Constitution which
is look at the law and administer it and
execute it and don't make it and don't
interpret it and there are a lot of
folks in this town that do that many of
them work for me and one of the various
places that I work I know men and women
who I can assure you without reservation
we're working just as hard for Donald
Trump the first day of his
administration as they were working for
President Obama on the last day of his
administration so as I sit here tonight
and talk about the bureaucracy I want to
make it clear that I'm not talking about
all of them but I am talking about a
very very important minority I don't
know what to call it some people call it
the resistance some people have called
it the the deep state and all of those
names have pejoratives I'll try to use
the term entrenched bureaucracy tonight
or the bureaucracy but when I say that
I'm talking about the folks who aren't
being good government workers and my
point tonight is that whatever you want
to call it the deep state the
bureaucracy the resistance my point is
this it's real it's not something that
somebody cooked up in order to win an
election it is absolutely positively a
real thing and it is absolutely
positively a challenge and a threat to
many of the things that a liberal
democracy and at some point I do hope we
have a larger longer conversation about
taking that word back you used it
tonight
thank you so much for using it it is a
term I hope we can get as I'm supposedly
a conservative and I work at a
government that spends four trillion
dollars a year I'm not interested in
conserving that so I do hope we get that
but that's another discussion for
another day but that entrenched
bureaucracy is a threat to the
principles that a traditional liberal
democracy holds the limited government
account
government efficacy of Elections that's
what I'm going to talk about tonight and
the challenge that we face and I think I
can prove to you that it's real and I
hope to give you just a few examples
from my time here as to as to the fact
that it is real and it's not it is not
some paper threat I got sued by someone
who works for me which is probably not
the first time that's ever happened but
the president asked me to go over and
work at the Bureau of Consumer Financial
Protection and on the first day I was
there I got sued by someone who works
for me because she wanted my job she
thought she had the job lost by the way
but let's let's think about that for a
second I am a political appointment the
president United States asked me to come
over and run a bureaucracy to run an
agency to run a bureau and a career
staffer a government worker went to
court to sue me to prevent me from doing
that that's outrageous if you stop to
think about the implications of that and
it's it's it's indicative of I think all
of what you see at a lot of different
places many of these folks really do
believe that they are in charge and that
they are not accountable to whoever the
particular political leaders were put in
place it's an extraordinarily dangerous
position to be in the bureau I've said
several times publicly I think is what
Elizabeth Warren set up to be the ideal
bureaucracy one that was completely
unaccountable and one that they really
thought would continue forever and ever
in her image regardless of who was in
the White House you hear Elizabeth
Warren say well it was meant to be
independent what she meant to be was it
meant to be dependent on her and
independent from everybody else when I
got to the Bureau of the very first day
guess how many political appointments
there were at that office one me that
was it I'm about 40 that worked for me
at the at the Office of Management and
Budget we have about 500 people there
there's about 1,700 to work at the
bureau I had one political appointment
quite frankly because the previous
leadership didn't need it to have
political appointments so the simple
fact that someone would sue in order to
prevent a political appointment
particular bureaucracy should frighten
you because they thought that they
really could go about their business
without regard to the outcome of the
election more recently I had somebody
quit on me again probably not that all
unusual all things considered about 2200
people worked for me and people quit all
the time this gentleman who would quit
quit by sending a letter to the USA
Today newspaper which they published on
the front page I'd never met the person
did not know his name had never seen him
in my life went to go talk to his
supervisor who informed me that he had
never complained about the job the
entire time that I had been there what
didn't he like apparently he didn't like
that we decided to enforce the law the
law says that the Bureau is responsible
for oversight of private student loans
okay you may remember this part of the
Obamacare legislation the government
effectively nationalized the student
loan business and the private student
loan market now accounts for about eight
percent of the market under the previous
leadership at this particular Bureau
they didn't care about that and they
were still regulating all a hundred
percent and I simply came in and said
look if the statute says we get to
govern private private student loans we
are going to cover private student loans
and that bureaucrat was so incapable of
operating within the law that he decided
to quit and to make a big deal out of it
by the way this also shows in many ways
how the media is complicit with this I
do always say they didn't call me to ask
him anything about it didn't ask me if
the guy had complained and asked me why
of the circumstances ever he wished it
was legit they simply printed the story
again another example of the bureaucracy
being completely detached from what I
consider to be the constitutional
reality they are supposed to work for
the elected representatives not against
the last story I have
and just not just as by pure coincidence
comes from the same Bureau because and I
wanna make this clear you could talk to
any cabinet secretary who's been in the
government for years and years and years
and they could tell you these stories
again and again and again in fact
there's I think just today there was a
couple stories coming out along these
same lines but there's folks as a very
small group they call them Dumbledore's
Army at the bureau and I didn't read
whatever book it comes from it's Harry
Potter I think yeah I didn't read that
one either showing my age now but they
had set out to try and make sure that I
was not effective in my job so what they
did some people call them leaks I call
the blinds but they knew our policy okay
because they're on the inside and the
policy was that we'd never comment on
ongoing investigations we will not
confirm or deny the existence of an
ongoing investigation so what they would
do is leak out that we had stopped
high-profile investigations mr. Mulvaney
we just heard a leak somebody's telling
us that you have discontinued your
investigation of Equifax would you like
to comment on that no I'm sorry we don't
comment on the existence or
non-existence of investigations printed
in the press that we had stopped the
investigations why to undermine what I'm
trying to do and to undermine the
President's agenda
it was completely false and we able six
months later to prove that it was false
as we came public and were able to say
now that we've complete our
investigation here's what we're doing
but we were not able to respond to it
for six months and they knew it so were
they doing this was a concerted and
intentional act to try and undermine the
President of the United States I didn't
know it was like this
I really didn't I have been in Congress
for six years there's members of
Congress here I know mr. shkolu served
you did right for allowing from Indiana
I had no idea was like this I had we had
seen bits and pieces of it if you serve
it and in Congress you see bits and
pieces of the bureaucracy and you'll see
it you'll read books and so forth and
you hear people give speeches until you
are on the inside of it you will not
realize how large and entrench
the bureaucracy is and I cannot state
enough what a threat it is I do want to
come here and tonight and just tell you
all bad news cuz my staff told me that
the speech is way too dark so I promised
them that I would also try and talk
about how to fix that very briefly
unfortunately that makes it even darker
because because the fix is is really
quite challenging the fix is to give
more authority to the executive okay
which on its face sounds like a very
very dangerous thing to do but I want to
make clear I'm not talking about more
authority to implement or interpret the
law I'm not talking about Congress
giving power to the such-and-such or
secretaries as you know secretary share
makes such rules to do thus and such
talking about giving the executive any
executive the authority to actually run
the government you would be stunned at
how hard it is to fire an employee okay
why wouldn't we give the executive the
ability to hire the best keep the best
and fire the worst doesn't that make
some sense wouldn't both parties
supposedly support that
and doesn't it demoralize me in fact we
just had conversations the other day
about how federal workers actually
demoralized because they know that if
they perform well they really won't be
treated that much differently from those
who perform poorly there's been two very
high-profile stories at the last 24
hours I think about undercover
interviews with with members of the
bureaucracy and what's the common theme
in both of them
they both say nobody can fire us okay
they know that and so do all of the
really really good federal workers so
not just for us from it from it from a
standpoint of doing the right thing by
the Constitution just doing the right
thing by the coworkers you would hope
that Congress would give us more ability
they don't in fact they do the exact
opposite last time I tried to when we
talked about the steps you had to take
in order to try and lathe people off
it's nearly impossible to do in fact the
only way just about the only way you can
do it short of something really
egregious is for Congress to simply not
appropriate the money and if Congress
wants you to keep that many people
working at that Bureau and they give you
enough money to hire that many people
you pretty much have to do it it goes a
little bit deeper than that one of my
favorite stories I've told that many
times and this is from the spending side
but it goes to how the legislature
doesn't want to actually get into the
details of the law but they love getting
into the details of micromanaging the
executive so you got as a situation
where the legislature is actually trying
to run the executive instead of trying
to run the legislature and my example is
this two years ago and by the way this
is the exact right crowd to tell this
story because you folks don't take this
money the I made a proposal in the
budget to reduce spending on the
National Institutes of Health which you
work with a large research universities
and of course every research university
in the country came to my office and
said this was going to be the end of the
world at cetera cetera et cetera and I
said no that's fine here's what we do
because would we give you a federal
dollar and thank the Lord you all don't
know about this you can spend like 30
percent of it on overhead okay which is
why all these universities have these
fabulous new buildings been paid for by
the taxpayer but if you get a private
grant from the Gates Foundation you can
all
and 10% and my theory was okay if we
simply reduce the overhead from 30 to 20
we can spend less money and actually do
with the same or more research and
simply not pay for the overhead and not
only that Congress ignore that they put
a line item in the next year's spending
bill that said it was against the law
for me to consider that again the next
year okay that is the type of
micromanagement we talked about and it's
in the exact wrong place the executives
hands are tied and until the legislature
decides to be the legislature and stop
being the executive I think we're going
to continue to have that problem this is
the point where I'm realizing I have the
notes here on my piece of paper that my
steps of this speech is way too dark and
if I painted a really grim picture I do
apologize for ruining your dinner I
don't apologize for telling you like it
is because it is like this and
and if we're going to fix it we need to
do what you folks are doing which is to
educate folks like Paul and like
Brittany that it doesn't have to be like
this in fact it's not supposed to be
like this if you actually read the
Constitution you'll see how it is
supposed to be and thank you for sending
us these types of people who can
actually help us to implement that and
thank you for also making it more widely
available through the work that you
folks to in your outreach as I close I'm
gonna break a promise I said at the
beginning that I wasn't gonna do any
quotes from famous people including
Jefferson but I have a couple people
that Hillsdale work for me they wouldn't
let me do that so I want to read one and
it's not really a quote from Jefferson
but you'll probably recognize it the
history of the present King of Great
Britain is a history of repeated
injuries and usurpations all having in
direct object the establishment of an
absolute Tyranny over these states to
prove this let facts be submitted to a
candid world he has erected a multitude
of new offices and sent hither swarms of
officers to harass our people and eat
out their substance obviously you
recognize that from a Declaration of
Independence I am NOT saying that the
entrenched bureaucracy is the exact same
as the monarchy of George the 3rd but I
am telling you that an entrenched
bureaucracy can present the same type of
threats to our individual liberties that
a distant monarch does in fact what was
one of the complaints about George the
third was that he was a distant monarch
day and he was unaccountable and
unresponsive how often we hear that
again about our own government today and
it's usually not your elected officials
it's about the bureaucracy they're not
physically distant we know exactly where
they are they're right here they're
within miles of this building but they
are psychologically distant and they are
certainly non-responsive and they are
certainly not accountable to you I'm
obviously not suggesting that we rise up
in armed rebellion against the
government over the intention Brock
recei I'll let Larry do that later on in
the closing
but I am sounding a call for people to
recognize that entrenched bureaucracy
can be just as animal to the rights of a
free citizenry as a distant monarch can
in fact to close I'm gonna do something
I'm gonna do something that I know has
never been done at a at a Hillsdale
speech before in fact this is the one
that's guaranteed not to get me put in
the in the newsletter I'm gonna read a
quotation from Leon Trotsky and when he
made this statement balance I'll read
the statement first I couldn't I
couldn't leave this when I found it
bureaucracy and social harmony are
inversely proportional to each other he
wrote that 1936 he wrote it I think he
was living in Norway at the time and he
wrote it against what was happening
happening in Russia with the Stalinist
regime because he saw what Stalin was
doing Stalin was creating a huge
bureaucracy in order to create a
despotic government think about that for
a second even Leon Trotsky who was no
fan obviously of a liberal democracy
knew how dangerous an entrenched
bureaucracy could be and I simply
suggest you tonight if Leon Trotsky knew
was a problem maybe we should as well
and we should be aware of the challenges
we face I will say this the folks that
you've sent us are aware of the
challenges the folks who work with this
administration every single day are
aware of the challenges we want the same
things you want we want a constitution
that works and that governs our lives we
want responsive government we want
electable government we want free
citizenry and we will do everything we
possibly can to make sure that we change
as much of what I've talked about
tonight as we can so with that dr. Arden
there's a true honor thank you very much
for having it
[Applause]
so thank you for that Oh Big O
bureaucrat bureaucrat that means rule of
bureaus that's the rule of furniture
we're gonna try to get something those
questions here constitutionally the
federal government is given numerated
powers with everything else left to the
states how do the 430 federal agencies
honor that's true as of today that could
be probably more that exists today fit
into the federal government's enumerated
powers
so when the class of 2010 took over the
United States House of Representatives
and again I'm going to be just as dark
in question and answer as I was by I'm
becoming a cynic that I feel like I've
earned it after eight years in this town
we passed a rule of the house that said
that with every bill that we introduced
you had to make a specific citation to
the section of the Constitution that
gave authority for the Act that you were
laying out in the bill that you were
offering okay guess which one was the
most commonly used by Republican members
of government the general welfare clause
yeah so the how does it fit in we make
it fit in is what it comes down to you
know you could go case by case as to
whether or not you know the Department
of Education fits the obviously
Department of State does so the answer
to question is it just we make it fit is
it ideal no but we need to do a lot
better perfect follow-up what what do
you think is the most the most
unconstitutional agency of the moderate
administrative state
strictly speaking I think the two trying
to get it's either energy or education
and I think it's probably education just
because there was such a tradition and
still is of having that be run by the
states the the energy was what 1977 and
education was not not too long before
after that and I think education was
first was 79 one of the reasons by the
way that when we proposed to reorganize
the government we actually merged the
the labor and the Education Department
together for a variety of reasons but I
think it's probably education I still to
this day when when folks call me and say
look you need to do this in public
education I'm like well where do you
live and they said Idaho and I'm saying
I've never been to Idaho why why would
you want me to have anything to do with
the education in your state but they
still a lot of folks see the federal
government as a court of appeals they
can't get what they want out of their
local government or their state
government so they simply come to us and
ask us to get involved and we do you've
been both a legislator and you're now in
the executive branch and you've
sometimes been criticized for having
been one in the other and there seems to
be some being consistency we actually
talked to this woman before your talk
how do you relate having been a
legislator and now looking at it in a
different branch of government in terms
of how all of this operates your and
your responsibilities one and the other
yeah that's easy I mean at least I hope
it's easy I mean I hope that you don't
blur the lines between what you're
supposed to do as a lawmaker and what
you're supposed to do as a member of the
executive branch it's pretty clear fact
I think we get in trouble when we start
to blur those lines we were talking
before about John McCain's passing and
how sad it has been that not only do
lawmakers sometimes think their
executives they're also unwilling to
actually execute the duties of lawmakers
back when mccain feingold passed there
was a bunch of people in the House and
Senate who said they're voting for it
even though they think it's
unconstitutional because it wasn't their
job to make that interpretation
President Bush famously signed it saying
he thought it was unconstitutional but
he was still going to sign because it
wasn't his job so I
the the transition between the two is
quite simple and while it might end up
putting you taking different positions
for example when I was a member of the
House I advocated for completely
shutting down the Bureau of Consumer
Financial Protection
and I haven't done that since I've been
there and I can defend to you that that
is the exact position that you should
want me to take as a member of the
executive branch what would I be doing
if I walk to say look I know the statute
is on the books and it says there shall
exist a Bureau of Consumer Financial
Protection
and it shall do these five things but I
McGrew to ignore that I'm gonna lock the
doors we're gonna go home is that the
right thing for a for a good bureaucrat
to do or should i instead sit there go
okay it says we're gonna do these five
things we're actually gonna do these
five things and not the other seventeen
things that they were doing previously
in the name of those five things I think
that's a much better way if you want the
real fundamental structural change that
we've talked about tonight
then the legislature needs to pass laws
to do that if you could go back to the
Constitution convention
and give the founders one's heads up
heads up about a future event in
American politics that they might use to
create a constitutional safeguard so put
a safeguard in and looking back and find
out what we know now what would that be
clarifying a clause something else
elaborating something I would have
warned and I always get this wrong which
is the one that got rid of the be a
misdirect is the seventeenth to direct
election of the Senate yeah I think that
was the that's where we law there was
that natural tension between the federal
government and the states and I think we
really lost that when we went to direct
election of senators I was in the state
legislature for four years and I can
assure you that my senators would have
acted very very differently on very
significant pieces of legislation if
they had to answer to us instead of
answer directly to the voters so there's
probably a lot of really really good
answers to that question but since we
just had that conversation my office the
other day that's a that's one that I
would put on the list
so there's several questions people had
about actually about budgeting and your
your background as a legislator and now
in the executive branch can help us with
this can Congress ever get back to
regular order for budgeting and we will
will we ever reform the problems of non
descript discretionary spending first
answer is easy of course that getting
back to regular order right now but
they're solving it in the worst way
possible which is they're just spending
more money I've always told people back
home be careful of how much
bipartisanship you say you want because
there's one thing that is bipartisan in
this town it is spending more money
that's how you get 20 trillion dollars
and debt you don't get 20 trillion
dollars in debt by one party sticking it
to you the two parties walk hand-in-hand
down that road and have all sorts of
excuses right I have to do it in the
moment but the end of the the end result
is you end up twenty trillion dollars in
debt as to the non-discretionary
spending so called mandatory spending
entitlement spending I know I was having
this conversation with with Christian
Cola before before dinner
look I can sit here all night and tell
you about the challenges that we face in
our entitlement spending programs so
folks don't like that word it's it's the
Social Security Medicare and a couple of
things that's not the problem right now
you are not one trillion dollars in debt
today on the deficit today okay we will
be a trillion dollars in the deficit
this year only about 38% of that comes
from entitlement spending the rest of it
is discretionary spending and I think
many of us in my party have convinced
ourselves that the entitlement spending
is such a problem that we've also
convinced ourselves that entitlement
that discretionary spending is not a
problem we increased the discretionary
budget last year by 13% 13% there is no
way that we can grow the government fast
enough to raise revenues to cover that
shortfall okay the goal here and the
goal that I've been pushing with in this
administration
I'm not givin up on cutting spending but
I can tell you I'm pretty cynical about
it just because I've been through those
types of those circumstances by the way
that the example I gave about the
National Institutes of Health funding I
could
you twenty of those with the legislature
literally ties our hands the next year
because we can't do it
they love spending money there's a
saying in this town there's three
parties Republicans Democrats and
appropriators and they love spending
money so I have sort of giving up on
actually reducing spending I'm more into
focus now in trying to slow the growth
of spending so that revenues can catch
up right now if you're growing your rent
your expenses by thirteen percent and
you're growing your revenues by four
percent that is a really bad place to be
if we can you know if we can grow the
revenues in by four percent and maybe
grow government gross spending by one or
two percent sooner or later or over a
period of time you can catch up but mmm
internal spending is a problem long-term
it's a longer discussion for another day
but right now the problem is real and
it's the discretionary part of the
budget several people mentioned baseline
budgeting okay speaking of dark and you
have things can we ever get rid of it
and okay basically this is my favorite
example of baseline budget last year
if you spend a hundred dollars on
something and your household and this
year you spent a hundred dollars you
would call that a freeze we call it a
cut if you spend a hundred dollars last
year and one hundred two dollars this
year you call that an increase we call
it a cut if you spend a hundred four
dollars this year instead of hundred
ollars you call it increase we call that
a freeze and if you spend a hundred six
dollars this year instead of a hundred
you call that increase and we finally
call that an increase that we are set up
to spend more money it's it's they don't
correlate perfectly but the 1974 Budget
Act the the the deficits as a percent of
GDP really take off in 1980 1981 all my
Reagan friends always cringed when I say
that but it's absolutely true they but
the Republicans the Democrats figured
out that time that Democrats Republicans
could cut taxes and Democrats could
still increase spending and everybody
could keep his and her job because they
were simply gonna borrow to make up the
difference but it was really the 1974
Budget Act that set up that type of that
type of spending curve by the way if you
wanted to be really cynical again if you
see a theme yeah okay again I do budgets
for living it's what I get paid to do
why is that convenient why hasn't it
changed and why is it gonna be so
difficult to change okay
we spent $100 last year we spent a
hundred and four dollars this year okay
you call it increase we call it a cut
you come into my office and you really
really like that program and I'm a
member of Congress and I could say and
thank you very much I want you know I
agree with you and I think that is a
really important program and that's why
we increased spending on that this year
so will you remember that and vote for
me in November thanks very much and when
you come in the next day and you're a
good fiscal conservative voter of mine
from back home I see you know what I
agree with you and that's why we cut
spending on that program last year so
would you vote for me in November so
it's it's been a very convenient way for
a bunch of people to stay elected I'm
gonna be more uplifting if I can get a
better
this is this is our last question so you
can answer it however you choose we've
talked about the budget people often
focus on the be in omen OMB tell us more
about the managerial side of OMB and how
you you were doing that what kind of
changes you envision to which I can add
how are you going to save the country
and give us an optimistic answer yeah
listen we just we just this it's the
coolest place in the whole world to work
and we do the management part people
always assume that we they know us for
the budget cuz that's what gets me on
television but the management really
takes up just as much if not this more
of our time to do it but some of the
really cool stuff that you've read about
coming out of this administration has
been driven by the management side of
things at the office of OMB the fact if
you had a chance to see that the Kevin
if you're watching daytime in cable news
at two o'clock in the afternoon or
Tuesday you need more to do but there
was a cabinet meeting and the president
turns to me in the middle of cabinet
meeting says make why don't you talk
about government reorg which is always
fun when you don't know you're gonna
speak on national cable television and I
it's when I got up to talk about pizzas
and chicken and I said well you know if
you make a frozen pizza and it's a
cheese pizza you're governed by the USDA
but if you put pepperonis on it you're
governed by the USDA and if you're a
chicken a live chicken you're governed
by the USD I always get this backwards
but you get the point the live chicken
is governed by the USDA it lays an egg
that's covered by the FDA you break the
egg it's now covered by the USDA again
but you freeze it and put it in a batter
it's covered by the FDA again that's we
describe that we have a policy for that
we have a name for that we call it
stupid
and the management folks are the folks
who are really running it out routing
that stuff out and saying look how could
we do it better the government is always
going to exist so the question becomes
how could we make it as limited a part
of our life as possible but still
effective
and put yourself in the in the in the in
the shoes of the guy I used to work for
a guy literally I didn't know this and I
mean I didn't know this was going to
come up when I was 14 years old but I
spent a summer one time helping a guy
who made frozen pizzas and I would put
the pepperonis on him and I played again
a machine and they would freeze him at
the end of the thing and I'm like I
never occurred to me that by putting the
pepperonis on the cheese pizza which is
all a pepperoni pizza is that he had to
move from an entirely different
regulatory regime and having the the
awareness that that's real having the
awareness that makes a difference having
an awareness that small business people
especially have to deal with that every
single day is an important part of why I
think the administration has been so
successful say what you want about the
president I've been critical I said look
there's one of our biggest challenges is
that we were brought up people a bunch
of people into the administration who
don't have any government experience and
Washington is its own sort of place
there are people who say government
should be run more like a business and
I'm certainly agree with you to search
that government is never going to run
like a business it's just not the same
we don't sell a product we don't sell a
service it's not it's never going to be
the same so none knowing a little bit
about Washington about governor's
helpful so it's one of our biggest
challenges that we had a bunch of people
who came from the business world but
it's also one of the biggest advantages
that we've had because I can tell you
men and women in this administration who
have worked out in the private sector
have brought that experience into the
into the government and they say you
know what when I when I was a look at
the president one of the reasons the
president was so excited about the
government reorganization about
bureaucracy is not affected in any way
it is real and it is born of the best
kind of background which is real
experience and when people come to him
and say I'm having trouble with the Army
Corps of Engineers he could look them
right in the eye and say you know what I
did too let's fix that and having that
attitude it's not academic
and by the way I get asked on clothes
with this because I want to talk to your
students for two seconds because I'm
still a frustrated academic kids ask me
all the time mr. Blaine I want to go
into politics what should I do and
without exception I tell them go get a
real life first go get a real job and do
do what the president did because like
the best men and women who come into
government are the people who realize
that government can be extraordinary
helpful the government can also be a
hindrance to success and bringing that
real world experience in can be a huge
advantage and to the extent that we have
improved the country in the last two
years and I really do believe that we do
I believe that people are better off now
and will continue to be better off I
think a large portion of why that is is
that we have so many people in here who
share my cynicism and also share a
passion to fix things so maybe that's
the most uplifting way to finish Thanks
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you